All right.
Well that was painful.
[LAUGH] That's the mathematics
behind sort of the general
way of thinking about prediction and
correction cycle of tracking.
Fortunately it gets a lot easier
when we look at specific cases.
Spec, specific models of how to do that.
What we're going to do in the next
one is look at a very very simple
analytic form of doing this
called the Kalmen filter.
We won't, we'll show you the equations,
we'll you the update, we'll show you
the intuition behind it, without
necessarily deriving the equations.
Then what we're going to do is show you
sort of a more modern approach using
it's referred to as particle
filtering in computer vision, but
basically it's this idea of using
samples to represent densities.
And when we do computing,
envision, robotics, et cetera.
The idea of using samples to represent
densities gives us a lot of power
because we're not limited to particular,
analytic, distributions.
So that will make those integrals,
either easier or
even better just simply go away.
So, let's do that next.